[Music]
so no problems between the different
groups here what do you think the world
has to learn from hasidic jews
your son's telling you to throw away
your smartphone yes
with smartphones we don't have internet
[Music]
there's a guy pandemic is like very
different did you have it yet
did they all have covered already they
all like
it they hit you with those things you
spent all day on here
sometimes i can see the goal fantasies
that's the 911
right right do everything that you have
on a daily basis
[Music]
here we are in williamsburg
uh schlum is finding a friend here that
knows this neighborhood
so it's one of the three i guess one of
the big free
orthodox neighborhoods in new york city
i believe he said it was uh i think i
got that on camera but
much more conservative okay so there's
there's our guy
how you doing i don't know if i could
come close to you or not because the
pandemic is like very different did you
have it yet yes of course
you've had it yeah six months ago
seriously
how was it tyson before facing wow
i was sick like a dog but now i have not
enough antibodies to save the whole
world
for real you're the safest place in the
world you guys are the safest guys
what's this neighborhood known for it
says shalom like jerusalem of america
you know it's the most
i thought we were just in the jerusalem
of america this is life the holy of
holies
what are we going to get into here he
wants to uh
show you my secret and he wants to see
how nice the sick is
a shack how do you say that though
it's very like it could rain it could
pour it doesn't protect from the winds
that's the most protected place that
there is
what do you mean we need to say that's
not the lacks and not the doors and
other
gates that's not a protection at all
going to a place where you're like
exposed to everything and you're the
protected most protective place
and this is the spiritual symbolism
behind the succulents
how do you know this guy this is the
most very dangerous guy we grew up
together
it can be i forgot syria
in syria yes damascus damascus high
school
is there is there anyone inside it asked
us to do that i have no idea what he
wants
you may have some something up his
sleeve i don't know either
like literally everyone got it in march
whoever didn't get it in march got
two three weeks ago and then we should
be done yeah i'm surprised that you
didn't have it
for real maybe you did you know i don't
hang out in these neighborhoods
you did i don't know i don't hang out in
these neighborhoods yeah but
uh where do you live jesus why are you
so afraid you know yeah i don't want to
get covered yeah yeah
huh you weren't sick when you got it get
sick you get sick
this is my house this is cool nice style
here
wow because now the holiday times
you know what this is right so let me
explain to this
he saw one on the street yeah uh this is
supposed to make you happy
is it working sometimes
you know i thought it was like when
those uh birch branches like
in the russian banya they hit you with
those things
nice now you got it going
every day in the morning we make like
love with hashem
he takes us around the back all over the
place
oh you never have this feeling you will
never have it probably because you know
maybe you will one day i don't know
what's the feeling like feeling is like
being loved by hashem by the creator
see if you feel god in this oh yeah oh
yeah
oh you see the four corners he takes us
around from all the four corners i was
telling you about the corners the
corners of the field
yeah we got these four corner garments
as well
what about the jews i see that are
wrapping the the wire around their heart
every morning you do that every morning
yeah and then you have the thing yep
little telescope
inside in here in this box
it's a box it looks like a box it's not
just a box in the box there's parchment
written all those verses that hashem is
the only one that is in control and
that's what you put on our hand you know
i put it on hand
can you do it do you mind doing it i
could do it but not um
so what does that do does it cut off the
circulation
so what's the what's this somebody told
you that no i
it looks like it does no it is like
because the
the might of a person is in his hand
right okay i believe because
he is very strong he makes a lot of
money and he's successful
he does a good businessman but this is
the show no we're not in control of our
hands
and then we put in our heads as well
over here right
yeah to show that it's not because we
are smart
and because we have a good head and we
have a good knowledge this is how we are
successful
hashem is controlling our hands and he's
controlling our minds and everything
else in between
i don't want to worry because i'm not
supposed to wear it today okay
because it's a holiday it's a holiday
okay i'm just doing it for sure because
you know he promised me that
if i do this then i go straight to her
he'll take you to his uncle's pizza shop
if you do i don't buy anything he's
telling me anymore you know
you guys all said you've all gone
covered
yeah yeah you felt it yeah oh it's like
a cold like a very bad cold flu
it was real that's right people have
died in the community
many many people do this was the hardest
hit community probably entire united
states
but most people who died had other
conditions most ninety-nine percent
older people people
a young healthy person with god's
protection should be able to get through
it
you can't see that we have young people
that die and old people that didn't die
dies
young people died did you say i'm sorry
yeah okay
it's it depends on god depends on god
let's say okay you will die
it can be young no corona what else do
you think about life tell me about your
neighborhood
do you like it is it cool like i see
god's world it's
very good god's world is really
everything like the sun
shining wow i everything you have to
thank god not like oh the sunshine
oh every day no every while the sun is
shining
and every every tiny thing you have to
thank god wow
if not you'll be you'll be
sad if you see and everything wow wow
wow
so you wake up every day you're happy
about the sun you're happy about
the sky
wow beautiful
what is it yeah i think so this was my
wife
she hung up all this and so how much
time are you spending out here
you spend all day out here he's
literally sleeping in there study
this is my house this is where i live
yes you see i love it
for for everything for a week and a half
eight days yes there's a custom to
to decorate the sukkah in a very
beautiful way so every family has their
own
style of flavor how they do it so what
do you think the world has to learn from
hasidic jews
and i know you're not converting people
which is very true
you're trying to
this is one of the things you're not
doing okay yeah
i think that's great so what does the
world have to learn from this
in general no just in general in general
that
we are created to serve god to serve
hashem
he created us in his image and we should
respect
ourselves because we're in the image of
god so
if we know that we're in god's image we
behave we should do only
more things that it's uh that it's
expected from us
i mean a lot of people do that not only
do we should run like that yeah
i think that's the basic message in all
the religions we all can create it
equally
all right guys where are we going now
look to the shul nice
town synagogue oldest room
the oldest
the modern world we're in 2020 yeah
the youth there's instagram there's all
this distraction
how how do you see the religion
preserving itself
the religion is going to be fine um
the culture let's say my opinion yeah is
that
the fact that we're hasidic jews
actually gives us the power
to even if we get pulled away from time
to time and we
and we might fall away from our
traditions or what we're supposed to be
doing
we also have this this this concept of
repentance
yeah and in judaism we're always happy
even if we fall we do something we
shouldn't do
you clean yourself up you get happy
stand up again and you
and you go on with life we don't focus
on the failures we focus on the
positivity
most of people in williamsburg don't
have smartphones they don't have
smartphones
that they do have because of business
okay it's restricted to business only
for example i have one and my son keeps
on telling me that daddy you know throw
it away you don't need it
so the kids wow your son's telling you
to throw away your smartphone
yes that's amazing
every parent wishes for that to happen
on another note this
is the zip code with the least probably
the least television subscriptions
in the whole city okay no no no
television inside
no television no facebook some people
have
i have it yes but uh the majority
of the hasidic jews demand facebook no
tv we don't have cable tv we don't have
internet
there's no interest no
[Music]
so you have the sky to look at the
clouds to look at
the environment the world right now
they should not busy with your phone and
you speak to that
like you go to the present and you will
visit
what are the biggest challenges now
would you say generally speaking is the
internet
it's the internet probably yes social
media
and the liberals the liberals
cuomo and de blasio the whole morality
of the whole world in general is like
it's
it's almost down in the drain there's no
there's no boundaries
we're abusing the natural beauty of the
world in many different ways
right believing that we have we're
getting pleasure about not the real
real reality right losing everything
right so i guess our forefathers were
smarter than we are
they knew much more than we know
although we believe that we are smart
but we're not
so that's why we have to study and
believe what we are taught
so we should not fall into the trap the
human body and the mind
that didn't change since it seems
what was created so they know how it
operates and
you know what what's happening after
right we do all the bad stuff
so that's basically it you agree to that
yeah i mean i don't i don't i don't
follow your religion
but i do think uh a lot of moral fabric
is is loosening i don't think that's
good i think family structure is
loosening
that's why i admire and respect about
your religion is it seems like
i'm sure there's all sorts of stories
but it seems overall
there's a strong family structure there
is a saying
somewhere in the bible that when you
drink water
that is stolen it's much sweeter than
regular water right
out of stone snow stone stone water
oh stop okay yeah it's sweeter why
because you know there's certain
ingredients in that does it you're not
allowed to have it and you have it all
that feels better
right but if you keep on stealing water
every day
it loses the value even the value that
even that value
is being lost right basically everything
that you have on a daily basis includes
the value
so you always have to come up with
different ideas
but soon you'll run out of ideas because
the human body is just
yes that magic can handle a lot of
african-american communities here
and there's a lot of hipsters and this
will see them and
it all mixes together in a very
interesting way
like we're we're about to walk at the
synagogue but look this is the the crowd
that's hanging out on the corner
right the colorful neighborhood very
colorful this is the block party
[Music]
wow what's that
synagogue's right there you saw that
interaction that was like
we can all get along it's possible right
so no problems between the different
groups here he lives here i don't know
no they just do drugs and alcohol but
they won't bother you
they'll just ask you for a dollar every
now and then but everyone's cool
okay if there are a lot of people i'll
probably uh
i won't stand there too long no we're
inside oh it's empty
okay i just want to show you this is
like the oldest synagogue in the
neighborhood
oh cool
[Music]
why do more men pray than women a man
has an obligation to pray every day a
woman doesn't
i'll enjoy this what's up there's the
bible
the torah the torah let's go keep it in
this and then we go see it the ark
get a peek this is a very old one you
see over there
all types of juice coming into this
place you know with the with their
regular blackheads with
jeans shorts no socks sandals
everybody's welcome over here it's
called oyofshala invariate of showing
that's the name of the show
even non-jews come over and pray
non-jews are allowed yeah yeah
everybody's allowed congress some
synagogues if you'd walk and you weren't
affiliated with the group or you
you weren't wearing the dress code you
might be uncomfortable praying everybody
says here
this one is open to everyone you are my
friend
right but the children like it's like
you
you're the same of the jewel but in the
other section
okay wait let's let's say that again
because take care of brother
take care let's say that again two
sections of flows two section of flows
yeah i have jews
close to me because i am my brother and
you all kills me because you are my
friend
gotcha jews are your brothers non-jews
are your friends
because he's not real brother
one of the things that that every
community has to deal with is that you
you live in a place you don't
necessarily get to choose who your
neighbors are
and you have to have peace and harmony
no matter what happens so
we live in a free country everyone can
do whatever they want to do right and do
i think
they love this music coming through
their windows probably not they probably
don't want the children hearing it i'm
sure they don't
right but that's just the part of life
when you deal with it yeah
you're thinking everything in life is
meant to be every
everything but what's happening is what
sometimes i can see the god wow i have
like i have the story
but sometimes i can't i don't see the
god but i know it's good
right right it's like like let's say
someone you want to catch the
plane any mistakes and then he
says that's the 911th name but crashed
into the twin towers right right
the best thing you could have done was
miss the plane
that is what then you understand what
wow what's you see what happened
so sometimes you don't see it thank you
is that a tough topic no it's not a
tough topic okay
open space synagogue that's your
guidebook that tells you
restrictions your headquarters for all
of the world yeah it's thanksgiving
every seven day every six days
[Music]
i need to try that some time on my wife
yes i don't feel pushed down
like when there's no covert when you
don't have to worry this place is full
if you're not a match you don't go out i
had this holiday the whole day in my
life i wouldn't enjoy it anymore i'll go
[Music]
crazy
you